[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Linc and I'm
Rhett is time for another conversation
with an interesting person from the
internet this week it's mamrie Hart one
part of what many fans are calling
YouTube's holy trinity which also
includes grace Helbig and Hannah Hart
previous guests on the show she's got a
popular weekly show you may know about
it called you deserve a drink but she
also just released a feature film camp
Takota which she wrote and starred in
alongside her youtube counterparts
Grayson Hannah
so we talked to memory about growing up
with a television star as a father
founding the topless Tuesday club in
college
and we traced the path from arriving in
New York with only $400 to finding a
career on YouTube and writing and
starring in her own feature film and we
talked about how her friendship with
grace and Hannah might affect her future
plans of course one other thing that
came up in conversation a lot was um
camp she we learned that she draws on
her own experience as a camp counselor
to write and form the story of camp
Takota so it got us thinking about our
camp experience right so I don't know
how old were we the time we went to camp
together this is fourth grade fourth
grade fourth grade and I just remember
the concept of camp even before we went
it was this thing that oh when you reach
a certain age summer time you get to go
away and I this is the kind of this is
the kind of thing that I got to be
honest with you I looked forward to with
great anticipation I'm which is I tend
to be tends to be what I do anyway I've
kind of build things up and I get really
excited about it but camp was this thing
that in my mind it seemed like the
ultimate experience because you get to
go away for one whole week I mean no
parents no parents you don't know any of
the other whatever you want to we were
going as friends you know we knew you
and you knew me and that was it
everybody else was gonna be a new friend
yeah my my mom took us drove us to
Western North Carolina to camp Carraway
now camp Carraway it
that kind of sound Carraway's it sounds
more like a like a like a retreat place
for adults almost like kids don't have
cares it's or like a rest home or
something but it but it actually was a
camp I always thought it was like don't
get carried away it can't carry away
well that would be carry can't carried
away but you're saying it was
there's no cares here you don't you have
no cares put your cares away like
carefree camp camp carefree camp
carefree that sounds like something for
old folks camp care away sounds like
yeah this might be for kids for children
now the only reason I didn't cry when my
mom dropped us off is because you were
there I was I just remember being so
anxious a lot of my childhood is defined
by anxiety I as I reflect on it now I
did I just I didn't put my finger on it
at the time that I was an anxious child
well and you oh so now you never told me
because I had playing it cool I was
nervous
get out by the time of my life you know
I mean now both neither of us took a
dump the entire week I was go ahead and
get that out there because there's
something about you just kind of pucker
up a little bit when you go to a new
environment but it wasn't because I was
anxious it was just because I was in
camp mode well the facilities were I
mean the actual toilets there was there
wasn't a lot of privacy there was no
there was a stall but there was no door
and I was like I'm waiting till I get
back home right so other kids can walk I
thought there was a door other kids
could walk in front of it unless you
were in the last stall and then if
someone came to check to see if anybody
was in there well they would see it yeah
I was I was anxious about that
personally and when you're a kid somehow
you can you can hold her for a week I
don't know how that works
I remember thinking when Wednesday
rolled around and nothing was nothing
was rolling out I was like oh man I'm
what's gonna happen you're gonna explode
Thursday comes up I'm like man I didn't
mix thinking that my parents are picking
you up and you're like wait can we stop
somewhere no idea I waited til I got all
the way home but I I mean the things I
remember about camp I don't remember any
of the other kids I don't remember
making any other friends but there were
girls there it was a co-ed camp right no
it was all it was only guys yes there's
only guys are you sure I'm
percent sure maybe was a I guess that's
why I don't remember any girl it was a
royal ambassador camp it was an RA camp
oh wait the GA camp was across the lake
or something yeah I mean there there may
have been a ga camp that was somehow
what are the GA stand for girl
ambassadors I don't know I really don't
they but no no definitely no girls I
remember a big swimming pool and I
remember going to that swimming pool and
not being happy about that because there
was a bunch of kids and I felt like a
lot of them were like dirty like these
kids been running around in the woods
and now they're gonna jump in a pool
with me why didn't you just I mean I
don't feel good about that why didn't
you just you never told me any of this I
found I find all this out when we become
adults and plus I'm not buoyant I
haven't done a number two and it's been
five days so I'll probably sink to the
bottom no see yeah I mean like all
there's a lot ends announcer this thing
but see the thing that says me here's
the thing that upsets me is that I had
the time of my life and we never went
back because you didn't like it it's
like when we go to a restaurant this
where this happens all the time now we
go to a restaurant I'm like this
restaurants good and then we get out
you're like yeah I don't want to go
there again and we never go back again
it's just camp Carraway all over again
now I don't remember ever telling you
that I didn't like it there was a reason
why when we brought it up the next year
it was just like I don't think I'm gonna
do that this year you never but you
wouldn't tell me why when I was afraid
of the pool and you know everything
really I didn't know where the geas were
and so I didn't get to go I think of all
the summers that I missed out on if my
mom would have been a counselor I
probably would have went back that's the
sad I remember our counselors name was
Jeff Cole Cole he had a mustache and
like really short military hair I was
like 22 but he had to he had a mustache
and so I thought he was 32 but now that
I think about it I realized he was like
right out of college and he was a weird
dude I gotta admit he was a weird dude
but you know I appreciated his
leadership you didn't you don't even
remember his name I just remember being
anxious were you scared of his mustache
I was afraid he was gonna leave us in
there I don't know I mean I'd never been
away from home that
long and held it that long if I said
that already you know just I don't know
man I'm sorry I do remember that once
your parents picked us up we went
directly from there to the Asheboro Zoo
and that's where we bought those
matching gorilla purple t-shirts yeah
that is that is the picture that we
posted online one of the first pictures
of the two of us together that has like
survived all of these years so in though
in that picture science class pictures
two young boys who have been holding
holding it for all they were weak we had
full large intestines that's crazy I
never thought about that when I see that
picture we looked happy at that point I
was just I just relieved to be with
people I knew but not that relieves so I
think if I were to write a screenplay
about that it would you know I'm pretty
boring be pretty be pretty sad at least
yeah if you think what we just talked
about was boring and yeah I think the
screenplay would also be boring but I
think camp Dakota they they feared they
fared better than that it had some more
interesting blood points okay mamrie
hearts fan base it continues to grow
she's got two YouTube channels you
deserve a drink where she makes drinks
for you but also has lots of fun and
they're like themed around a celebrity
or an event or something like that and
then she's got mametown which is a more
personal channel and both of those are
really taken off continue to take off
and she also I might add made it quite
possibly the most hilarious cameo in an
hour video Christmas face as the on
screen makeup artiste and she's making a
cameo if you want to call it that on
your biscuit so let's get right to it
our ear biscuit with mamrie Hart
[Music]
okay so last time we saw each other yes
was that the Dakota premiere it was just
like a preview yeah
sneak preview an excuse to all have
adult beverages outdoors party I think
it's what the official name and we had a
ball we had our pictures taken thank you
you guys were killing me you were taking
all the pics wrapped up in a blanket
just yeah well it camp theme we go with
a theme you guys anything we go with a
theme you guys want that green carpet
but you congratulations but yeah on Camp
Takota right yeah yeah it's really
exciting super exciting it's like more
exciting for me as a writer even than an
actress okay be like oh it's doing well
but rhett told me that you told him a
story that I didn't get to hear about
leaving Christmas fails so I wanted to
hear that from you okay so when I left
Christmas face and I was and full-on
what would you call her she was a makeup
artist by day a little trashy lady of
the night by morning and so I had that
crazy makeup done and then as soon as I
left because I was running late I had to
get on a phone call and I didn't want to
go into the parking garage and lose
service in the elevator so I just walked
around downtown for like 20 minutes and
people and then I got in the car and
like rear viewed and was like oh you
still just have to shirt on too right I
had like a cardigan on okay no but it
was still a still a poison flesh and
blood tour 1987 yeah halter-top haltered
homemade halter top well it was it was
perfect for what we needed
I love dying it was perfect for downtown
perfect for meeting the streets downtown
yeah me too I've got some new clients it
was great but no one no one approached
you to tell you that uh no because I was
on such a intense phone call like they
thought I was breaking up with my pimp I
can only imagine or setting up the next
appointment exactly mm-hmm
it was pretty awesome well and the video
looked great oh yeah your your your
appearance was amazing
the comments were raving oh thank you
contribution so we should we should do
more of that type of stuff I'm into it
more holy [ __ ] we gotta make up
something else though yeah Christmas
sweats Christmas face Christmas we don't
know I don't want to start thinking
about it is a bit early yeah way to the
Weather Channel least till July guys
come on yeah okay forget I brought it up
now I'd love to get into your creative
process right off the bat just you know
in watching your videos
I love the bloopers at the end and live
for me that kind of I find myself trying
to analyze your creative process and and
find the clues of exactly how you do it
in the bloopers like okay she looked
down there as she finished this improv
riff she might maybe she has written
down some of her lines and then she's
just kind of riffing off of that
obviously there's stuff at the top of
the head so that's how I look at the
bloopers and also they're hilarious
so I mean for clues I'm just fascinated
with with with how it all comes together
well there is pre written jokes there
are pre written jokes essentially I
think about some silly puns grace comes
over we have a pregame cocktail we think
of a few more and then we just we get up
we intro make the whole drink and then
it's we bump in for a joke time so I
have the preferred joke you know it I
don't like go back and forth it's just
like here's how I make the drink and
then it's like all right now we're just
gonna shoot jokes for like the next 15
minutes or so okay so we have some
prepared because some of them are you
know pretty in depth but then it's me
just riffing and essentially trying to
make grace Helbig laugh that's the
that's the ultimate goal is to get her
to break behind the camera has she been
there for every episode every episode
really every single episode grace and I
know each other from New York and we
were on our first sketch game sketch
team together like six years ago or so
and then we also lived in the same
neighborhood in Brooklyn so we would
spend many a day getting Bloody Mary's
at like 2:00 on a Monday
and I wasn't doing any Internet stuff
yet but then I had the idea for why dad
and we lived you know really close to
each other so we just I'd walk up the
long hill so you shoot these now unless
this your your house your apartment my
apartment yeah so she comes over she
comes over yeah and it's just like you
only shoot one at a time I assume I mean
not always because of schedules and
whatnot you can kind of plan like if
it's a pop culture one obviously you're
gonna shoot at the week of but if I'm
doing a pop culture one and the next
weekend is st. Patrick's Day then we can
go ahead and do a st. Patrick's Day one
so you can kind of tell how many was
shot in a day depending on my level of
drunkenness cause if we're doing like a
three like a three-wide dad day oh yeah
maybe number three is pretty loose yeah
we might not even find the footage so
you you know these drinks are I don't
know so little about mixed drinks are
you men finding these I'm inventing the
internet finding the right bar attended
through college and I also bar tended
for like seven years in New York City so
I'm using my like base knowledge and
then kind of jumping off you know
traditional drink drinks are just making
ones up and just you know seeing if they
taste good cuz you have to have a bit of
a palate for that for sure yeah with all
different like infusions and so I mean
how much of the how good of a drink this
is going to be it goes into the process
this is like I want you two guys who
enjoy this 100% because hey I don't want
to drink something gross and also the
that nothing makes me happier than when
I see that people actually made the
drinks at home which the drinks that
tend to be made are like the most
white-trash ones like I had one Amanda
before amanda bynes that's literally cup
cake vodka champagne food coloring then
it's dipped in funfetti icing like
that's the drink and that's the one that
gets made the most that's because
everybody already has that stuff lately
if I'm like we're gonna do walnut look
cooler with you know cardamom infused
bourbon they're like oh I've got
funfetti in my pocket right now that's
what the kids are calling it
yeah yeah I mean you'll bring out these
bottles of stuff that's like whoa the
budget for this thing just went through
the room but it's all tax-deductible
right all tax-deductible I didn't
realize that the first year I did why
dad and then the second year was like oh
my gosh let me show this to the
accountant I'm like I swear I swear my
drinking is a write-off
yes great but I do have a kind of
ridiculous liquor cabinet
it's ridiculous I did well I just have
so much crap I'm never gonna finish I
did a drink a couple weeks ago that had
Galliano in it do you know what that is
no it's like this crazy huge guys go
with them though oh yeah it looked like
that building in San Francisco yes but
it does I don't know the really skinny
pyramid is that what you're talking
about earthquake building that is the
right bottle mm-hmm and now I'm never
gonna drink that but I just have it
could you had to mix a little bit in
hello Burnham so yeah it's pretty
impressive I mean you don't like have
parties where it's like all right just
have at it but you gotta buy a ticket or
something I don't have open houses with
cake walks and come to my home carnival
were raising money for me it's my
favorite cause I love those by the way
when we were kids I want a fish you want
a fish I didn't want a cake a fish and
that fish got a growth and died ooh
Wow yeah like a cancer they didn't very
large cancer didn't splurging for the
good Goldie's at your elemental I think
was something in the water now you asked
about our Fall Festival experience yes
we come from the same place right yeah
North Carolina represent raise up I
should say oh right spin around your
head like a helicopter yes yes I'm very
tempted to do that at this moment but
I'm not going to because well yeah it's
weird yeah exactly
so anoint like born and raised in North
Carolina I was actually born in New
Jersey and moved to North Carolina when
ios7
okay so you remember some of Jersey I
remember like memories of Jersey yeah
like what what are your um Jersey
memories I've never been there you never
been in New Jersey well I didn't live
in the part of Jersey where people think
of I feel like people from the south
when they think of New Jersey they think
of like Hoboken or like just somewhere
really dirty
no Boca and listeners I lived in like
super rural New Jersey and like had a
meadow behind your house and you know
old house small town it was like a
little Township called Andover and the
memories I have the most of Jersey is I
lived in an area that had all these
little independent theme parks have you
ever been to one where it's like oh this
is a family-run little theme park I
think you mean petting zoo right well
yes there was a petting zoo with rides
there was the land of make-believe there
was a place called the gingerbread house
that was like this big house that
someone spent all this money no turning
into yeah I feel like all those roadside
weird things on attraction stuff where
there was a lot of those where I lived
in my first few years in New Jersey yeah
okay so did that make you sad to leave I
mean I'm Lee is there a gingerbread
house where we're going there's barely a
house where we went why did you why did
you move what was that we moved because
we had family in North Carolina and also
at the time my dad Segway my dad was an
actor and the show he worked on was in
Georgia so we wanted to move to the
south but not on it yes no because my
parents already like separated so it was
like let's move closer so we're a five
hour drive but like let's be near to do
your cousin's and stuff meaning you live
with your mom not your dad but your mom
moved you closer to your dad yeah okay
yeah well that was that was big of her
yeah I mean it wasn't like a George or
anything no yeah she was like I'll go as
far as North Carolina but you're gonna
have to move to where her sister lived
and all our cousins were okay yeah okay
so your dad was an actor yeah I did not
know this yes in what at the time was he
working on at the time he was on an 80s
cop show called in the heat of the night
with Carroll O'Connor yeah all in the
family of course I was his follow-up to
that my I have a special place in my
heart for Carroll O'Connor because he
reminded me of my grandfather Clyde who
passed away I might get sad oh my god he
had a chair he looked just like him look
just like yeah and he had a head like
the flat same haircut and he had a chair
the Archie Bunker chair yeah his house
no one else sits in it hey yeah no one
else said and it was exactly like the
show and he would sit down and watch it
and then so like everybody
my mom always loved the show and watch
reruns because it was a connection with
her dad and so now we have that
connection
also a major racist the fondest memory
he even hated being white just because
it was a rest his ideal was just to be a
skeleton yeah right yeah moved in North
Carolina and was this like culture shock
I mean you had a meadow in your backyard
in Jersey but what do you remember about
the transition I remember hating that
people called their mom's mama oh you
hated that I hate and now I do now it's
about mama but like at the time everyone
sounded like so slow to me cuz I was you
know I'd lived in New Jersey so I wanted
slow not intellectually
just you know I just was really not used
to the I was I would get pissed off when
people would say ain't like I'd be like
ain't is not a word but I was like a
little sass as a second grader third
grader yeah
mm-hmm and what part of North Carolina
um my town was called Boonville and has
one stoplight and it's at like the base
of the mountains okay yeah so between
like Boone and winston-salem
got it yeah rural one stoplight
oh yeah once once the elevation really
starts changing in North Carolina you
know that's when you really get into the
good stuff the real good stuff so you
were there with your mom and like her
sisters were nearby see like a dance do
you have siblings
yeah I have an older brother and an
older sister and they were with you guys
there mm-hmm
and you would hear about dad the famous
was I was like oh I got a famous dad
who's down in Georgia like telling your
school friends and stuff no I mean that
was kind of just please from a town of
like 1,100 people everyone knew it
before we even got there
yeah because I mean going back to that
time right you know something you knew
somebody that was involved in
entertainment I mean that was very few
and far between I mean we didn't I
didn't know anybody that I had an
interaction as everybody knew about like
if you lived in the middle of nowhere
and then like a guy from CSI was moving
to your town right yeah which is a dream
of mine exactly it was definitely like
that it was he'd come up like every
month but oh so your parents did live
together they live together till I was
like three when my dad got the show okay
and then he moved and then we moved to
North Carolina but he was still like
come up okay all holidays we'd spend the
summer with him so we'd spend the summer
on the set of he the night and stuff so
your parents were civil they weren't
together but they were friendly yeah
there are a hundred percent yeah no just
kind of like you know faded the marriage
faded there wasn't like I've never seen
my parents fight or anything like that
and what did your mom do my mom is a
high school teacher still is still is
high school English yeah she was evil
well she has to commute there isn't a
high school in my town yeah she's a high
school English teacher in North Carolina
hating every second our students know of
Mamre in her channel that I don't know
because my mom remarried so we don't
have the same last name so I don't know
if my mom brings me up I doubt she kind
of mentions me in class considering my
subject matter right she does want to be
like hey everyone go listen to my
daughter say probably not ideal
honey because my dad is a law professor
okay oh wow and has been since we moved
to North Carolina in 84 and he does talk
to his law students about me because
they somebody figured it out and it was
like Dean McLaughlin is raised Rhett's
dad and then once they somebody found
that out
just rides that wave all the time oh
yeah but also like let's let's get real
our content is very different so what
what's your mom like and is it oh I've
watched your video and but you know is
this is there a dynamic they are with
your mom's like I can't show this to my
no my mom doesn't really bring it up my
mom's just stoked that you know I'm
being able to make a living being
creative we don't like you know go back
and forth on my jokes does she have a
similar sense of humor or no yeah you're
like a departure definite departure my
parents are both super funny but they're
not like crass whatsoever so we don't
like go over the latest why dad but
she's super stoked about camp Takota
that isn't filthy yeah or even my second
I start a second channel named town and
it's just like really goofy so she likes
that two things she could possibly you
know I have my nephew's watch and she
wouldn't be terrified right so she but
she gives you positive feedback she
focuses on that yes exactly
at this point oh she's super stoked she
loves it I mean my mom and dad met when
they were in they were both in the
theater department in college so my mom
loves you know in a different world she
would have been an actress and so yeah
she could she couldn't be prouder that
I'm I'm doing it
guys I'm yeah you're so from a young age
did you want to follow in and it sounds
like both of their footsteps in terms of
this kind of entertainer when I was back
then I was begging for an agent
really I was like please let me like
there was a hot minute I was like let me
go live with dad let me I like I need an
agent I need to do this but you know I'm
so glad that didn't happen a because
there's nothing worse than seeing kids
rejected in the entertainment industry
or like crazy stage moms right but also
because I really enjoyed the upbringing
of
living in the middle of nowhere so what
were you doing there was evidence of
this desire were you like performing on
street corners oh yeah
the one at the once I know I remember me
and my friends I was like you guys let's
just cheer lead let's just cheer lay it
on the streets
so I'd be like cheerleading I remember I
was like I cheerleaded I mean what like
traffic yeah Cheerilee in the traffic I
remember someone pulled over once and
was like what are you raising money for
and I was like nothing I'm bored and
then we remember any of the cheers for
the traffic no I mean they were probably
very probably just about me I'm not sure
there's one time we had like a piano and
and I took violin for a few years when I
was little and my mom came home and I
had taught to my next-door neighbor how
to play like two songs on the piano and
then I was gonna accompany in it
accompany it I can't say that word with
violin and she came in and my like three
old lady neighbors were sitting in our
living room as we played and I had
charged them you had you had sold
tickets
I had charged it I'd think I charged a
dollar Wow
but probably my life is worth seeing
it's worth paying for right right but
probably my favorite me performing
money-making schemes that I ever did was
my sister and I and another guy on in
here the Knights daughter decided that
summer while we were on set that we were
going to make her on horror movie and so
we made our own horror movie called
night fright and I was a killer and they
were two house sitters that I was you
know trying to murder and the film uh
I'll call it a film was about 15 minutes
long and during the in the in the hit
the night wrap party we made programs
like with our like actor BIOS we we had
a separate room we it was at someone's
house so we like had a screening room in
the living room and we charged people
five dollars to come watch our movie and
people you know they felt pressured to
because they were at a party and we were
kids in our queue and in the program it
said all proceeds will go to dare drugs
yeah we made a hundred bucks and we went
to Six Flags I mean way or another
you didn't do drugs that day exactly
what it takes for we just abused their
money there to keep us three off
for like a six hour period exactly to
feel like we're on kid drugs and Wow
were there any like pangs of regret for
that no it's a pretty great story dippin
dots have just come out so my ass was
getting to six laughs yeah it was the
ice cream of the future yeah right now
it's just above the present I guess a
little bit of the past yeah I know okay
so you would go to the to the set of in
the heat of the night during the summer
isn't it yeah what is that like it was
cool because while they were first of
all craft services as we all know that's
the best I mean just a dream I would
like go to the makeup trailer and like
make them give me makeovers I mean in a
very sweet way it wasn't like a bratty
kid like we're all friends and then I'm
a huge soundstage all these different
sets so while they're shooting in the
police station me and my brother and
sister are in the fake courthouse
pretending to have a trial or in the
fake diner pretending to be waitresses
it was basically just your playground
yeah running around the different sets
did you ever weasel your way onto the
show um no I actually did some
background work which you know wouldn't
you do a background actor let's say you
make like 80 bucks for the day a hundred
bucks for the day I was like I'm Logan
like I couldn't believe it
but it was between me and another
daughter on the show to get one line
that was hey mister can we get our
frisbee back and they gave it to her and
I was she got like 500 bucks hey mister
can we get our frisbee back did she also
get the frisbee back yeah yeah it was
part of the scratch not at all she got
it all but you were at least standing
next to me I was standing behind her
with hair down to my butt parted in the
middle huge glasses looking like Joan
Baez an entire shirt like I'm getting a
hundred today gonna cool hundo Wow yeah
so what was it what was it like for you
growing up besides the summer trips I
played all the sports even though I was
terrible at it like I still played
every sport I remember going to like
convincing my parents to send me to
basketball camp at Georgia Tech once and
it was like god bless them for not
crushing my dreams because like why did
I need to go to an expensive it wasn't
probably expensive but why did I need to
go to a basketball camp when I like rode
the bench I was so bad at sports but I
played them all and then I also danced
how's the big what kind of dance ballet
tap jazz yeah I danced growing up and
then I am I taught in high school and uh
and then when I did the summer camp
thing you know camp Dakota's based on I
did a dance instruction there really so
that was kind of close to your heart
actually being a counselor or a teacher
oh yeah for sure so what do you think it
was that made you want to get involved
in so many things because there was
nothing I mean there was really nothing
to do in our town you know it's not like
you could even walk somewhere and get a
slice of pizza and play a video game
like there really literally nothing to
do so I feel like everyone was kind of
always doing any extracurricular
activity they could and was it kind of
like oh I'm gonna get out of this town
one day I'm gonna be yeah I didn't wear
that leather jacket and just just stared
into the rock yeah I wanted to go to
college yeah it was I I had a really
great time I love that area but there's
a zero way I could live there so where
did you end up so I went from there to
UNC Chapel Hill ooh oh I know I know I
was actually texting with DJ Flula
before I got here and he was like are
you watching the UNC Duke game and I was
like no I'm gonna go record with rhett
and Link he was like of course those NC
State Wolfpack errs would make you
record during is this something that you
would
apart from Flula influence would you
definitely be watching it right now you
know I'd probably be a toss-up okay
yeah I wouldn't like be at home watching
it by myself because you know it wasn't
gonna be on Thursday until I got snowed
out last week and then got snowed out
soon no I wouldn't intentionally cuz I
would actually hate to a minute I do
watch that game you yeah I know it's
even an is an NC State Fair you have to
just as a North Carolinian but I will
say I pull for Duke I'm sorry I just I
don't know what it is I just can't like
it I cannot like you and see it I like
you it's been fun and my wife went to
UNC oh really
so you know I I can overcome a lot okay
yes a Rhett's wife went to UNC and going
to see state we had to we have to hate
UNC forever
why we can still watch your content okay
as long as disassociate yeah we're just
gonna disassociate that I'm just going
to pull out my metaphorical men and
black thing and just pretend I didn't
know that I'll see because you have
trouble liking us now - no we're good
okay good good you probably actually at
UNC it'd probably like a year crossover
with my wife
yeah not that you know that's what Mayor
was thinking about so what did you what
did you go to UNC for what was what was
the mindset at that point with that it
was just I knew I had to go and state
and so that was the school I wanted to
go when I went to college I really
didn't know what I wanted to study okay
like it always been in my head that I
was gonna be a performer of some kind
but I definitely did the whole like oh
you you don't have to have a major you
don't you're not gonna know what you
want to do until your sophomore year so
I ended up doing drama and
communications but you had to be I mean
obviously you were involved in a lot of
different sports and stuff but you
obviously had to be a good student to
get into UNC yeah so you were an
overachiever um or just an achiever I
think I was an achiever like I I had
good grades and stuff but yeah I wasn't
like studying all night or anything I
don't know what what was your high
school I'm flipping the tables know if
need to be like I just got good grades I
didn't like yeah I don't know you're
just smart some people are smart no I've
lost it all in college by the way oh
really
all of it I
the war student in college the fact that
I graduated on time is shocking what
contributed to that I never went to
class ever
I went five weeks without going to a
class one okay hold on how does that
happen because I got one I took classes
that didn't have a tendency Allah sees
and then like it's bad I don't don't do
that kids I still have I still have
recurring nightmares that I'm I realize
that I have to take a final for a class
I haven't gone to a semester and then
it's like like besides a bad grade it's
more like I can't believe I have to walk
into this classroom and people are gonna
be like who are you and it's because of
that but well it's a common anxiety
dream I have it all the time
I need to take the final exam and I
haven't gone to class but but I actually
did go to class you're just having a
flashback dream you're not having an
anxiety dream that that's just mine um
so what are you doing for the for these
five weeks are you like a hard partyer
like yeah I I had I lived in a house
with my really good friends are really
good guy friends live beside us we
shared a yard I mean it was how crazy
did it get mamrie give us give us a
point a point of point of reference here
okay I mean case in point is what I'm
actually trying to it was just really it
was silly collegiate we had like we had
three beer pong tables in the back I
threw a party once with six kegs we like
it was I had a club called topless
Tuesday I mean like it was just about
that it was women getting together and
learning a new skill or craft or whatnot
on tuesdays as they smoked cigars drank
bourbon and did it all topless okay no
this sounds like a fabulous idea yeah
it's great because you know what I saw
so many girls become comfortable with
their bodies when they join that club
okay
topless Tuesday don't let's do a baby
what was your this is your ID under your
range child yes me and my friend Melissa
what was your um what what made you
think of this idea weight tells your
motive just the two of us one day just
had a great day just topless doing
something and we were like we should
invite other girls along you were just
like just hanging out topless joking we
may really listen to this biscuit
they'll drink at that point I think we
were just crafting or something I don't
know you know college coach College was
weird you were you would you were
crafting topless yeah with your friend
yeah okay sexual at all but you weren't
thinking hey I will invite a lot of
women and they can grow comfortable with
their bodies that was a sight if the
next day it was like that was so fun
like getting drunk and smoking cigars
and and crafting and we were topless and
it was Tuesday that's got a ring to it
we invited a few girls to join and then
and then like people had heard about it
they're like oh yeah no you guys have
that Club I want to come to it so then
the next year I like the next semester
me and my friend Melissa who founded it
we invited people to be in the club like
they got formal almost like you would in
a sort like a sorority bid we like bid
we brought you like an invitation and a
glass of champagne and we're like
everybody gets in well I mean it wasn't
like a it's not like people applied and
didn't get into topless Tuesday we were
just like hey you know me exactly it was
really it was one of the highlights of
my college career I want to hear okay so
you were UNC you were majoring in drama
drama and communications and media
production and so what point were you
like okay I kind of think I need to go
to class and figure out what I'm gonna
do my senior year I finally actually
auditioned and and did a play which is
actually rocker Rocky Horror Picture
Show which was awesome so my senior year
that's kind of when they lay the things
out that you have to go to you know
there was a class where you have to work
in the wardrobe department for six weeks
on a production and you're just gonna
live there so once I had to be there I
really enjoyed it
and and that's that's when it solidified
that oh I'm moving to New York from here
mm-hm
but up until that point it was like um
who's going to get the beer
it just wasn't thinking about my future
at all so New York was that for theater
or just acting in general acting in
general but I figured you just had to
start with theater and so what was your
approach did you hitting the ground in
Big Apple Big Apple I moved there very
very poor I moved to New York with 400
bucks uh did you know anybody yeah I
knew I moved up I moved in with a girl
that I had actually been a camp
counselor with and and another friend of
hers but everything was just I didn't
understand what safety deposits were or
like what is it the person who rents it
out like the fee for the like the person
who shows you the apartment I'm really
bad with words right now I don't like an
8 they have like different work there's
a different name for it in New York I
can't think of it anyway so after all
that was said and done I moved up there
with like four hundred bucks and an air
mattress so hitting the ground running
was hitting the ground trying to find a
job mm-hmm so I found a job my friend
still a very good friend to this day
runs a like a post facility recording
studio and so I was front desk so it was
cool because I got to see actors coming
in to do voiceovers and bands coming in
and I think it but then meanwhile I was
just surviving off whatever bagels they
put out that morning right and then and
then once I got kind of my feet wet
about nine months there I started just
trying to find auditions for myself
yeah and that was tear and they were
terrible they were it was a terrible
experience do you have an agent at the
time no what made him terrible it was
just you know when you don't have when
you don't have an agent or a resume and
you're just applying to everything you
know forget even being paid for it like
totally free work but just the actual
work they were putting up I always
compare it to it's my go to comparison
of do you watch the the little show
friends I don't see no you're with have
you seen it I have so Joey Tribbiani
would also always be in these
productions where it would be like Freud
in space like that I felt like those
were the auditions I was going on and
they were just so embarrassing that I
wouldn't even want my friends to come
that I decided alright I'm gonna have to
be able to create my own work and that's
when I signed up for my first comedy
writing class and from that class is
when I got put on the team with grace
Helbig and so that was UCB that was the
people's Improv Theater so I was on a
house team there and I did a two-person
show there and then I moved to UCB and
did you see B for four years so UCB is I
mean that that was the like the step up
you just couldn't step into UCB and say
hey I want to be here no audition wow it
actually works so we were at the
people's Improv Theater first and I took
a couple writing classes there but
mainly I just started doing shows and so
I cultivated this two-person show called
both best of friends with my friend
Steve and we were like you know what
let's submit a script to UCB and see if
they'll give us an audition show even
though neither of us had taken classes
there which is like kind of kind of not
common to do a show there unless you've
been through the ranks okay and we got
in and we did a run and from there I did
several shows and and then I hosted my
own show for like three years and I
really just snuck in through the back
door I never took a class that used to
me sorry really yeah so at UCB that they
have classes where they teach you improv
yeah but then you can just be on one of
the teams we audition it's like crazy
they audition like I don't know the real
numbers but let's say they have let's
say there's 80 people on their improv
teams they probably have like 900 people
audition like it's crazy
so you made that team we're on a certain
night I was on a sketch team yeah I was
an actress on a sketch team okay
yeah and so you learned the ways of
improv not by a class but by actually
doing in front of people
yeah well improv isn't super my jam I'm
really into sketch I'm really into
written comedy okay I love improvising
onstage like with friends and as a host
but I don't do traditional
I don't do improv team it's like I'm not
gonna I would be terrible if I had to
just walk on stage and be like hey
you're 30 minutes late Joe we gotta get
to the theater that was pretty great
well I was 1802 prob yes so sketch
comedy has always been my love I love
the writing process I guess that's the
thing about improv where did you
discover that eating where did you
discover that the writing was something
you're interested in I think it was on
that first team on that very first
sketch team when you when you it was the
first time you really like write
something and then hear people laugh who
don't know you that was the first time I
was like oh I want to do this all the
time yeah and how did you I mean did you
know from the beginning that okay comedy
goes without saying her no when I moved
to New York it was to be a serious
actress really yeah and then when I had
the I had the emotional breakdown and
you know my friends and such were just
like why don't you what do you do it
like your faith you have a Lucille Ball
face like no offense
you can probably act very well but like
your face isn't made for drama it was
like you're right I should give it a
shot because I've always been like the
goofy ridiculous person but I really
enjoy dramatic acting so I was kind of
you know suppressing the comedy side and
then I was like let's give it a shot and
it felt right so do you feel like you
know now that the your comedy thing is
is really starting to take off you can
you see down the road there's an O and
then what I'm gonna surprise them with
that dramatic performance and lers so
yeah lots of people do Robin Williams
write those well actually I cry in camp
Takota how well I know I was gonna bring
that up first of all great performance
thank you at every turn
thank you but then there's that moment
towards the end well that's you know we
don't want to spoil it listen it was
very compelling I think and I I was like
we
we didn't stop just just talk about it
at the time but I was like she's doing
that thing where she's actually making
herself cry that's that's for real this
is not I'm not acting thing where she's
actually crying no this I'm just gonna
I'm making the assumption that you
didn't do the whole bring in the onions
you know because it definitely didn't
seem like that it seemed for reals yeah
we shot that scene we shot that scene
three times yeah Wow medium and close
yeah so okay well what is your thing
what did you do do you think about a sad
thing yeah that's kind of you know you
learn all the different methods and you
know when you're in acting school or
college for acting and that's my go-to
is just to think of something just
really really really sad in your own
life
well can you can you tell us what you
were thinking well I'll tell you I also
get teary during a no spoilers but a
fight with Grace and Hannah and that one
and so we had to like get to that level
and so then I just don't I said I just
thought about if you guys came up to me
tomorrow and we're like we've decided we
don't want to be friends with you
anymore and I was just like and I would
just be crushed so in that scene against
them you were actually feeling with the
rejection of yeah okay well I'm kind of
being rejected it's really tough to talk
about a movie without saying what
happened in the movie yeah yeah it's
difficult but it's intriguing you got to
start figuring that out so we're like
we're like baiting you and then also
with the with the crying scene at the
end it was towards the end of filming an
actual movie we had like two days left I
was just really sad about like leaving
the crew whatnot it really did feel like
camp when we were shooting the movie so
that was really just like I this has
been so great I don't want it to end
yeah I don't know like dig super deep
and be like this is about my uncle in
nineteen no I do want
I mean you've helped me discover all I
got to do is think about Carroll
O'Connor yeah and I start tearing up
about my granddad there we go yeah you
find your triggers and the Heat are
eautiful I can't tell you how many times
that's been sung to me
it's pretty good friend to probably
friends five years now and every time he
emails me he attaches the YouTube video
of those it's unforgettable yeah okay so
you began to get some traction with
comedy writing and the sketch thing
mm-hmm
and where was where was that headed
would you know pre-youtube you're right
were you thinking all right you know I'm
gonna break into a sitcom or you know
what go
are there people around you who were or
are kind of oh that person is on the
sitcom an hour that's kind of the path
with UCB right that's totally the path
and um well it's where you see where
there are other people that you were
thinking about what they did it so can i
well they did it so could i well like
when when we were at the people's Improv
Theater Ellie Kemper from the office and
whatnot like she got it from people's
Improv Theater and Kristen Schaal was
there and there were people who are
starting to make that leap and then at
UCB it was you know once once a year two
people go to SNL and and I had peers who
were getting you know late-night writing
jobs and things like that and I just
yeah I'm very I'm very driven by like
peer success not in a jealousy way but
just like yeah that looks that's so
awesome that you get to do that I want
to do that too let's all rise up
together and and there's also just the
migration of New York to LA and you
start to see people do that and when
they're in LA things start really going
for them okay so I knew that that was
gonna have to happen so I'm curious how
there was kind of this there was a maybe
a fork in the road for you that has now
led to the YouTube traction whereas with
other people it's the writing gig on
television or the sitcom starring rural
type of a situation
I thought the fork in the road for me or
what I thought was going to be the fork
is that I thought I was gonna have to
choose writing or performing okay so I
would bounce back and forth of you know
oh I just I really want to perform I
need to do more that too man I really
enjoy the writing process
I think I might be better at that and
what I think YouTube did was be able to
kind of converge those two wait you can
do both
so how did that happen how did the
YouTube thing start becoming a factor
for you
it started becoming a factor we started
doing your deserve a drink and I was
still doing a lot of stuff at UCB but
it's really great at UCB to know
graceless people's Improv Theater still
she did she does traditional improv as
well so she was on like a Friday night
team and would do that and I was all in
at UCB but I guess when it really became
a factor is just the numbers king of
this sounds probably really a
traditional comedy but it's like I can
beg and promote and grind to get 80
people to this show next week or I can
put up a video and and this is like you
know early days where it's just like or
I can put up a video in like 5000 people
saw it like that's right five times my
town I grew up in and so I started to
kind of put more focus on it than I had
before so what was the genesis of the
first YouTube video because right off
the bat you had you had the show right
uh-huh
so how did that work was it the the
writer mindset bring him together the
bartender thing cuz were you bartending
- yeah you said you don't you didn't
feel like five years bar attended until
two years ago okay so you're like I'm
putting these two things together and
I'm exactly exactly grace was doing
Daily Grace and she was she was killing
it you know she was a few years in I
think it was just when she started to
really like have people like show up at
her her theater that were fans things
like that like she really started to be
like oh this is a thing this is a thing
outside of our little life in New York
City people know who you are
and like I said we were hanging out
during the day all the time I was like
you know I have an idea for a silly
video you deserve a drink where I can
actually teach you how to make drinks
but with really bad jokes and the first
one is for Charlie Sheen like during his
meltdown right tiger blood gimlet and my
rationale was always because I know how
cruel people can be on YouTube was well
even if people think I'm an idiot and
hate my jokes they're still learning how
to make a drink that was my crutch of
like and I still to this day get
comments that are like god I hate your
face but hey that mojito looks delicious
at this point do you I mean do you start
to think I'm going to not do the drink
part and I'm just gonna do me I mean you
have the second channel that's just
that's I guess that's what that is
yeah but but it's more of just kind of a
side project kind of a thing in terms of
YouTube how do you see that
I'd love I really really have fun doing
mametown and I feel like all the other
things I'm working on or like trying to
develop or more in that sense of just of
just me I guess and just doing weird
stuff I always want to keep doing the
drinking thing I can see I mean there's
definitely certain limits it limits
things it's it limits age you know it
limits some people just don't drink but
I love it and I've been loved drinking
so I always want there to be an element
of that in my work really I'm writing a
book and and there's going to be recipes
throughout it and yeah it's what I
really enjoy what's the book gonna be
called dad I don't know I mean I'm
hoping it could be you deserve a drink
but I dunno chose Tuesday wow there is a
chapter on topless Tuesday yeah okay
he'll buy wet all your listeners
whistles which sounded gross in that
context so with with the success of what
you're having on YouTube and then you
know with being able to write hacked in
a feature film awesome
has the focus changed you know because I
think that still a lot of people who
have the talent that you have that you
could easily see you getting snatched up
into a sitcom or something like that
right is that so like oh yeah that would
still be really awesome
or is it like you know this internet
thing is sort of become a thing and I
you know we can do these independent
projects like camp Takota
like house
change I still totally want to do
television and film the thing is is the
I always want to continue doing the
YouTube thing 100% that's like my main
might that is my main focus but figuring
out like everyone is trying to do how
you can find that happy medium because
like you know old habits die hard if I'm
eight years old wanting to get an agent
to be on TV yeah I still want it I still
want to be on TV it's just you know you
have to check that off but um I don't
think it's a lot of people like oh well
you know the internet are you using it
as like a stepping tool and it's like no
it's one of the blocks I want to have to
build whatever my life is going to be I
always want it to be there you know how
has the Uni talked about how the fans
kind of recognize that okay you had to
form this friendship mm-hmm with Grayson
Hannah and then you guys were making
videos because you're friends and you
all do the same thing yeah once as
people kind of start recognizing that
this is a thing yeah was camp Takota a
reaction to that or was that was it a
plan all along
interesting we met Michael Goldfine
who's the producer of the movie he
actually met Hannah and Grace and they
were like he wanted to create a project
didn't know what it was but wanted to
create a project with youtubers and they
were like you should meet our friend
mamrie and you know at that point it
wasn't like because she's on our level
you know they're they have much bigger
audiences with me but I loved the
writing aspect of it so we got together
and met and I actually I had 20 pages of
camp written in its first form and I was
like I have this idea for this movie a
woman blah blah blah life falls apart
and Michael who was a camper through and
through growing up was like I love it
I've always wanted to make a camp movie
yes let's like make this movie so that
was already a thing in my head but it
wasn't a thing starring three people in
my head so it was it was breaking it out
to where it could be this like this
story about these three girls friendship
but still the whole the whole way she
gets there and whatnot was was the same
right so it was
it was it was your friendship with them
that kind of led to your involvement in
the project but it was your idea that
ended up changing making the project
yeah yeah because of the friendship yeah
so I mean how is that do you guys now
you know it's because with the two of us
obviously we've been best for instance
we were six years old it's just it's a
given that any entertainment project
that we're gonna work on we're gonna
work on it together
yeah of course now that you guys have
this you know relationship and you're
working together is it like you know
what we should you get together and you
talk about what should we do next as as
the trio the trio
I mean we're definitely working on some
things and we had the thing is is that
making the movie was just so much fun
and like like my goal is just to
continue to find ways to get paid to
goof off with my friends on a set
essentially and so we definitely want to
do things together but you know they're
busy girls too we all have our own
things going on so I'm trying to think
of someone else and like who always ends
up doing movies together or let's say
like you know like the three amigos like
Steven Martin had other films and things
you know what I mean yeah but then they
went but then when they come together
it's really fun that's what I would love
to do with Grayson Hannah is be able to
do our own things come together have a
blast you know and just just interweave
through each other's careers I think
would be fantastic but it is funny now
that people are aware
I'll see things on tumblr that's just
like I think Grace and mamrie are
pushing Hannah out since the film and
I'm like it's been four days and also
like we got lunch yesterday we just
didn't Instagram but yeah like they just
think they need like their dose to make
sure that we're still friends and it's
like guys we're still really good
friends yeah we we just don't always
record it it's okay I think it's you
know we experienced that in doing good
mythical morning every day that we get
comments I think that I think I sense
tension yeah why not there okay yeah we
get the it's very frustrating for us but
I
guess in the end it's very it's a very
good sign that someone cares so much
that like their their connection to us
hinges on our friendship with each other
right that they care so much about it
but it's also nice too because
especially the the age a lot of the age
that people are watching it is it is
kind of when you're still figuring out
how to be friends you know you have that
time where like you know what it's like
to be eight and ride bikes but like when
you're really figuring out how to be
friends as like a teenager you have like
good friendship models to kind of look
up to and and you know try to emulate
and so if there's tension like all is
lost right exactly yeah
how am I supposed to you know but we're
all fine guys there's a fanfiction that
when guys would do the nofilter to her
you guys would act out fanfic the the
extremely suitable for work fanfiction
because there is otherwise oh yeah you
didn't act out any other all-ages show
okay so we'll save that for our
Amsterdam leg of our tour yeah there's
some there's some stuff there's some
yeah hey you know what I say it keeps
kids right and I'm on board it's so
creative and a lot of it is really well
written so well I enjoy writing I mean I
oh yeah I saw your one the other day
reading my work three hearts beat as one
[Laughter]
yeah we get a little bit of that but
yeah I've heard about it but I haven't
read any of yeah exactly I can't bring
myself to it's so funny I love it and
then people all the different ships that
people do they get really intense about
it like to a kind of ridiculous degree I
mean do you know about all this like
shipping Moors yeah and like people get
pissed off when other people ship and at
the end of the day it's like hey guys
none of us each other spoiler alert
we're all friends so slow your roll so
so now what I mean there's yours
still kind of on the the crest of this
initial wave of camp Takota oh I haven't
been sober in a month pretty exciting xa
yeah but you said that you're there's
other things in the works there's other
things in the works right now right now
I'm doing the whole going on auditions
and writing the book but then I'm
definitely you know hit the ground
running to get another as we know movies
take a long time to make so I want to
start making one ASAP and I just want to
like ride the coattails of Camp Takota
to try to get people to you know believe
in another project and and that's I'm
just want to use it as leverage to be
like people will come people will watch
it if we build it so yeah I don't make
more movies I want to want to develop
more things with my own voice well we're
excited to hear the voice and see the
see the eyes it's gonna get weird I
can't wait yeah well thanks for making
an air biscuit with us thanks for having
me this biscuit was delicious it was no
Bojangles but it was good we should get
some that shipped here yeah definitely
[Music]
okay there you have it our ear biscuit
with the one and only mamrie Hart
I think it's cool and you know getting
to know her better and kind of hearing
her story just the fact that from a
young age she knew that she wanted to be
an entertainer she was inspired by her
parents by being on the set with her dad
and then you know she steps out with
only four hundred dollars goes to New
York to pursue her dream scene one path
but then Minh a lot of ways I guess due
to her friendship with grace and the
traction that grace was getting on
YouTube she kind of switched tracks and
now finds herself being able to make her
own right and star in her own movie I
mean that's that's where we are in in
the industry and it's just cool that
someone who was felt like they were made
to do this is able to do it has
unprecedented opportunity and she did it
without the help of her father too you
know I don't know what his status in the
world of entertainment is now but I you
know when she said I went to New York
just like anybody else no one would that
had a dad that was on a TV show just
went to New York with $400 and kind of
made it happen and you know she's a
truly talented individual and just very
funny great actress you know I was
really impressed with camp Takota and I
get you know I'm excited for her that
she's able to do this and she's got this
big push and then can think about
writing a book and all this stuff on top
of it and and now we've talked to all
three of them though you know this
that's the thing that I thought about we
talked to grace we talked to him and we
talked to mamrie we got to find another
group of three amigos
yeah as she called it we got to find
another trio do you know where to start
no we could add somebody to us and we
would be one I guess maybe maybe that's
what we actually should be thinking not
who should we talk to but do we need to
that's not a bad idea and then how would
we go about taking applications for the
night maybe just a pet maybe we start
small like if if we got like an Internet
pet you know how people get pet even
married has a dog I got it how about
like a monkey oh gosh
because I in a lot of these it's not
even a pet that's like an actor a lot of
these you two monkeys are smart a lot of
youtubers are doing things right I'm
gonna get this cat or I'm gonna get this
dog and put them in my Instagram and
everything's gonna be great I don't want
to I don't want that kind of pet you're
talking chimpanzee or my pansy is a
primate I don't want to know the
difference Queen a monkey in a primate
but I think you've got to start with a
monkey okay you don't want I mean
chimpanzee pansy is like 99% the DNA
matches us that would be like this
heaven like a third person around
well that's what I'm kidding I know but
I think that's too much to take on at
all at once I think you turn on you yo
yeah and they'll rip your face off
unless they're young a monkey will throw
his feces on you I definitely heard
about how they'll do that but that could
be entertaining there could be a whole
channel of him doing that I mean you you
don't even know how many times I've come
close to doing that to you you're not as
far as things that cross your mind yeah
it's just I don't have any on hand
alright so alright anybody is a monkey
out there that listens to your biscuits
if you're you know if you're thinking
about potentially getting on YouTube or
having a career in entertainment we'll
dress you up in anything you want you
can play an instrument that's even
better we've reached a new low not only
are we thinking about having a monkey as
part of our comedic duo but we're also
addressing them as if they listen this
is sad they're hey listen I there is a
less than 1% chance out there I mean
that there's a monkey out there
listening to us right now
really he's probably not in control of
the audio but he's somebody's pet monkey
right now they're listening and he
started looking at them right now things
like they're talking about me George I
said George because I was thinking about
a monkey right here is George the man in
the yellow hat is listening to this ear
biscuit and George is looking at him
okay I'm shaking my head right now and
discuss an apology this goes out to all
of you non monkeys out there thank you
for listening thank you for leaving a
review on iTunes it makes a difference
and tweet it
mamrie her twitter handle is main town
in Miami town and let her know what you
thought also tweeted us give us the
feedback we do this every week for you
Friday afternoons and we will be back
again next week promise
[Music]
[Music]